in
[Music]
this week on q a national review senior
editor jay nordlinger he discusses his
book children of monsters which looks at
the lives of the children of 20
dictators including stalin mussolini mao
idi amin and saddam hussein
[Music]
jay nordinger what were you doing in
albania in 2002
well
i was on a little state department
speaking tour
there's a boast
hasn't happened since
but it was very interesting
that was yes in 2002 about 10 years
after the collapse of communism in
albania
that the country was still in bad shape
and i think still is
but it this book i'm holding on to with
hundreds of names in it children of
monsters came out of that trip yeah
yes well
albania had suffered under a terrible
dictatorship really one of the worst
man has ever known the dictatorship of
enver hoja
the thing closest to it was the
dictatorship of kimmel sung
in north korea
albania was like hoja's personal dungeon
no one left the country no one came into
it it was almost a perfect
tyranny
and so i was being shown around uh
torana the capital by a young man from a
government ministry and it occurred to
me to ask
did hoja have children
because i couldn't imagine being a son
or daughter of hoja what do you do do
you stay in albania do you go out
how do people treat you how do you face
people what do you think what do you
like
and i'm a magazine writer so i'm always
looking for my next meal as a colleague
of mine says what's the next magazine
topic and i thought oh the hoja children
and he did have children three of them
could make a good magazine piece
and in the next thought i thought well
you could do a survey of such sons and
daughters and make a book of it called
children of monsters
and i filed that idea away like i filed
most ideas way off the stove not even
the back burner but i acted on it years
later
hitler mussolini franco
stalin tojo mao kim
hoja
i can continue on which one of these 20
that you profiled in here did you find
where the where the
the
family were the most difficult with
other human beings
that is a close competition
um
the stalin's had a lot of trouble
that shouldn't surprise anyone
the mao children were
a mess
are a mess maybe i should say
pol pot has a daughter who seems pretty
well adjusted believe it or not
he had her pretty late in his life he
was about 60 61. she's a young woman of
about 30 got married last year
the bokassas were are
disastrous
there aren't many happy stories uh out
of dictators families but there are some
that's a video we got a lot of video of
these
children and some of the
our uh dictators here's jean-marie larae
who was
he was a claimant his mother
who was a french peasant girl during
world war one
said
that hitler was the father of this child
this boy jean-marie laurae and she
didn't inform him of this until he was i
think about 30. he denied it at first
for years was tormented by it
and then became obsessed with the
question and became convinced that he
was in fact the son of hitler
and most historians say that hitler had
no children this claim is not true
but what's important for my book is that
he thought himself the son of hitler and
what effect did that have on him
answer pretty bad
he is talking in french we'll just watch
a little bit of it
he looks a little bit like hitler
well that's one of the big selling
points of that case and so moreover does
his son philippe
looks a lot like hitler
one of the things i say is
any number of french women could have
told their son
that the german soldier father he never
knew was hitler any number of french
girls french women
why did this one's son have to look so
much
like hitler
it's a little uncanny now of course you
didn't have to grow that kind of
mustache did he
that's his embracing this
believed identity
and it's creepy did he have any of the
characteristics of a hitler
i'm not sure
i think he was a fairly normal man until
he became obsessed with the question and
it's a question that would i think make
anyone a little bit nuts
i try to be somewhat sympathetic because
say one fine day
you've never known your father and you
knew he was a german soldier
and all your life you've been called a
feast bush really kind of a bad phrase
for son of a german soldier in france
and you're an adult about 30 i think and
your mother says you know
that father you never knew about
he was actually the late chancellor of
germany hitler
that is a card dealt to very very few
people very few and so i try to cut him
and some of these others some slack
although it's very very hard to cut him
slack for his admiration
of hitler is from april the 29th 1945
benito mussolini and his mistress
claretta batachi
this is the gas station in milan i think
it was an esso station they've been shot
before murdered the duche and his
mistress his main mistress
and now their corpses are being hanged
what was mussolini's
approach to his family and how many kids
did he have
he had officially speaking i think he
had five i'll have to check the book
officially speaking but a lot of these
dictators like other men it's true have
kids off the books a lot of them had
lots of kids off the books
and he was a good father i would say on
ceremonial occasions what do i mean by
that he would kind of swoop in and play
the great papa you know the great potter
familias when there was some crisis or
something but mainly he was busy i would
say being dictator of italy though his
children absolutely adored him
it got a little complicated for his
daughter etta
whose husband mussolini executed
that's kind of a fine how do you do if
you're a daughter
who and she loved her father and loved
her husband counciano his one-time
foreign minister
in fact there are other daughters in
that book
whose husbands were killed by their
father that's a very
ticklish thing
here's a some video of uh the wedding
is it
you call her ida or edda she's etta
uh-huh era mussolini
being married in 1930
and you say mussolini had her husband
killed
yes
so this was a grand affair this was one
of the great occasions of italian
fascism
the the wedding of a fascist princess
etta
with a fascist prince young count chano
and chano became mussolini's
father-in-law's foreign minister
but then there was a rift
because channel voted the wrong way on
the fascist grand council he voted in
effect to restore powers to the king
this is when italy was clearly losing
the war
so
mussolini as you remember is imprisoned
by the king then he's snatched by the
nazis and they set him up in a little
rump government in northern italy
and china was caught and slated for
execution
and this drives at a wild and she pleads
with her father but the father will not
stay the execution and china was
executed
and for a while edda says my name is
anathema to me i'm no longer mussolini
but eventually she
forgave
and loved her
late father and her late husband in
equal measure it's a very strange
psychological case in 1995 we have some
video of her funeral oh
this i've never seen
and this is 1995 and they're saluting
her
in the muslin good old fascist salute
yup not yet out of style
how active are the fascists in italy
today
they're a rump they're a remnant but
they're very enthusiastic they don't
have much electoral success
although the leader of neo-fascism in
italy
is none other than
mussolini's granddaughter alessandra
we've got to see a little bit of
alessandra on this this video is this
year
and she is on the floor of the european
parliament
let's uh this is an italian let's how
does she look brian i can hardly
adonostato
islamic
do you get all that a bit yeah
what what's her story and she was i
think in the italian parliament before
she went to european wasn't she she's
had a long political career she's been
in both
chambers of the italian parliament the
house of deputies i believe and the
senate and she's been in the european
parliament she's a somewhat big deal
her father
was romano mussolini
one of mussolini's sons uh romano was a
jazz pianist
performed with
ali fitzgerald and dizzy gillespie and
all of them
and he married his first wife was the
sister of sophia loren
so
let's reason this out together so
alessandra is the daughter excuse me the
granddaughter of mussolini
and the niece of sophia loren
the greatest star in italy
one of the greatest stars of the 20th
century
so
alessandra has quite a heritage
and she's very faithful to her
grandfather's legacy and she is a
so-called neo-fascist
interestingly enough
she is rather supportive
of israel and disavows a bit
of her grandfather's anti-jewish laws
i have to tell you this is probably my
favorite clip for reasons that have
nothing to do with dictators but uh
some of the people watching will
remember alfalfa and buckwheat and
they'll remember spanky and darla here
is vittoro
uh mussolini who is you have him in the
little rascals yes we do and he is he is
a son of mussolini and he was besotted
with the movies and wanted to make his
name as a
movie a writer about movies and a
director and a writer and a screenplays
and a big shot and he was a big shot for
a while but world war ii kind of killed
it this is brief but on the left the
adult on the left is hal roach who was
the producer who he had come to meet and
if you listen closely after the foreign
language you'll be able to hear spanky
and darling all saying some brief things
terrific
[Music]
i'm glad to meet
the little rascals and what's this
what's the point of this
well
vittorio and hal roach formed a pact a
business agreement they were going to
produce movies together they were going
to produce as i remember grand operas
starting with rigoletto
but and this was just before the war it
might have been 1938 or so but hal roach
took some heat in hollywood for this
alliance
with mussolini's son and at first roach
was defiant and he said i believe this
is a direct quote using the language of
the time he said benito mussolini is the
only square politician i know square
meaning straightforward honest uh but
the pressure was too much and roach
bought out vittorio and so victoria
wasn't able to
consummate the deal so far what we're
seeing is not that vicious
uh
who
who is the meanest
of all your 20 dictators
the sons and daughters the dictators
themselves the dictators themselves
there's no way i'll give you an answer
but with a preface
there's no way you rank
hitler stalin
pol pot
bokassa amin
francois duvalier others i i don't think
you should get much into the ranking
business saddam hussein
but i want to tell you something about
mao or give you an opinion about mao
well not my opinion but those the
opinion of those close to him
there is something especially chilling
about him i would say because he seems
to have been devoid of human feeling
he seemed he seems to have been so
clinical
he
saddam was saying forgive me for saying
so
you can kind of understand he had a
volcanic temper he was a human being an
outrageous human being a human being who
engaged in great evil but you can sort
of see a person in him
mao
is almost a robotic he's an ideological
robot
and he views the hundreds of millions of
chinese
as so much
experimental material
he wasn't happy he wasn't sad he wasn't
mad he wasn't he was just
detached how many kids did he have
he had about 10
he knew about
four
really the others died in infancy were
given away uh during the war the civil
war he didn't really care much about his
children apparently
and what what happened to them after he
was gone
or even while he was on earth the
daughters that the two daughters live on
as kind of ceremonial figures for the
chinese communist party
uh there is a grandson who is a kind of
general i say a kind of general in the
army he was promoted really based on his
name people sort of mock him
he's apparent a little bit dopey he's
quite chubby doesn't look like a
military man
mao has a granddaughter who is one of
the richest women in all of china her
husband is one of the richest men
in all of china
but mao's children as perhaps goes
without saying led very very sad
turbulent
lives just very difficult lives the only
video we have of this is li na who is
mao's
daughter
and this is a visit to uh yanan in
northwest china in 2015 this week this
year really
this this is the the only child i
believe that mao had with the with the
wife we know as madame mao
how many times was he married
i think about four
he tended to discard his wives
for others without telling the original
wives
when how did you go about doing this and
how long did it take it was hard it was
very hard to get information about these
people there's a great stinginess
about information concerning dictators
families also there's a kind of omerta a
code of silence
around many dictators families and the
legacies of those families it's a very
tight-knit thing after the dictator
falls
so but i describe myself as a kind of
scavenger
i even i think in my afterward or in my
note on sources i describe myself as a
garbageman i was digging around for any
scrap any tidbit i possibly could
because these sons and daughters
most of them some of them are famous and
important some of them become dictator
but most of them are footnotes and
decides
and you really have to dig to find out
about them a few of them write memoirs
but i think most of them keep their own
counsel
and so you just
pick up things
uh an historian a visitor a scholar will
remark on a dictator and there'll be a
stray remark about a family member and
if you're me writing this book you go
aha and that's real gold to you although
to someone else it may be just as i said
an aside
people today would probably know the
names uday and kusey
who are they who were they
i think senator mccain described them as
those lovable scamps
uday
they were the two sons of saddam hussein
they were little monsters they're an
example of boys
who were the monstrous reflections of
their monster father in fact
a renegade a dissident general georges
sada
in a book called saddam secrets
says that uday and kusey were a hundred
times worse than saddam himself that's
hyperbole of course but as i think i say
in my book
once you get to know uday and kusey you
can sort of forgive the hyperbole
because they were awful and in
particular
uday i shouldn't say too much about him
but he was a monstrous person
who
tortured and raped and murdered and
terrorized his way through life
video we have
he's firing an ak-47 during a party in a
restaurant
[Music]
[Music]
he's just born he's trying to create a
little bit of excitement
i don't think we can see it but but
there there are lights strung
in the form of happy birthday
uh surely in arabic and he shoots the
lights out and musicians duck and all
that he just did it for fun he
he kept constant chaos around him he had
total license in a country of about 27
million there was one person one human
being who could stop him and that was
his father and his father sometimes did
and mainly didn't how many times was
saddam married how many kids did he have
saddam was
married twice some people say three or
four times he had one let's say original
wife her main wife and then a later in
life one he never divorced the first one
he had those two sons and i think three
daughters
two of the daughters married brothers
who were cousins of saddam
and those two couples with their
families defected once
to jordan
you recall this brian and they stayed
there under the protection of king
hussein for maybe half a year
and they were enticed back home
and there was a lot of bloodshed after
that what happened to him
the husbands well
the husbands were promised
safety reconciliation
they're immediately made to divorce the
wives saddam's daughters
they were stripped of their
military ranks they were sent home to
their father's
villa
or compound
and then there was a great
gunfight a battle and they were killed i
think within about
48 hours of returning home
did you were you able to talk to anybody
in iraq directly yourself about these
children and what happened to them
yes i was able to talk to some
knowledgeable people i couldn't talk to
any family members
which was
usually the case in the preparation for
this book there are only so many around
to talk to and only so many willing to
say what they know or to develop their
feelings or experiences
at all it's a very touchy business being
the son or daughter of a dictator but i
was able to find out quite a bit
about saddam's family
and one of the daughters
is a bit of a public figure
she lives in amman she's in jordan again
she was one of the defecting wives and
she's a great loyalist to her father
though her father killed her
husband in fact she is nicknamed little
saddam
she's a great supporter of isis she's
wanted by interpol
she's a bit of a fashion plate she goes
to the finest boutiques in amman she has
tons of plastic surgery
she's in jewelry design and she is a
keeper of the saddam hussein
flame
and why the
government of of of king abdullah the
second
maintains her shelters her
i'm not 100 sure
the history channel did a documentary on
uday and kusey and they came to a
fairly familiar end we'll watch 20
seconds of this
folks can see it
a ferocious four-hour long firefight in
series
later that day after troops stormed the
house word comes from central command
about the results of the raid
four persons were killed
during that operation
and were removed from the building
and we have since confirmed
that uday and kusey hussain are among
the dead
two days later these gruesome pictures
confirm the identities of the day
[Music]
for many iraqis the death of hussein's
two sons is cause for celebration
because under their rule
iraq had become a living hell
what would those two men do to others
physically when they were alive
a lot of the people in my book
um
order
torture and killing
a few of them like to do it themselves
uday certainly liked to do it himself he
liked to get his hands dirty
he
tortured and killed
a great many people a great many and
never suffered from it never was he
could do anything he wanted
he was the kind i mean girls are not
saying that he could abduct and rape the
daughters of ordinary men that goes to
that saying he could abduct and rape the
daughters of provincial governors
of high officials
he was untouchable except by saddam
and except for this
there was an assassination attempt
and he took some bullets
and partially paralyzed him
and when the saddam regime fell
our soldiers found in his uday's
collection of things i think about a
hundred canes
some of which most of which i think
functioned as firearms
how did you divide up how did you pick
the 20
i went for what i thought was the worst
of the worst the very worst dictators
modern dictators i didn't go back into
antiquity
you could have done caligula for example
you could have gone to the middle ages
for
ivan the terrible who
killed his son with it
his scepter
uh the czar killed his son with his own
scepter and immediately regretted it and
this was a rage and was mortified by it
there's a famous painting by reppin
of this moment so i didn't do that and
so i i
i picked the ones i thought were the
there's some subjectivity here
there are a couple who really don't
belong
there's one i feel sort of guilty about
um
franco doesn't belong in a book called
children of monsters he doesn't belong
in a book with stalin and mao and idi
amin and pol pot and all the rest
he was a dictator and you and i being
good democrats wouldn't want to live
under him or any other dictator
but as i say in my book sometimes in the
dictator business we grade on a curve
and he was a lamb compared to these
others i included him maybe i shouldn't
have but i included i'll give you my
reasons and people can decide whether
they're good or bad reasons they're
probably bad
he's famous
people know of him
and they may wonder where he is
he had a daughter who's led a kind of
interesting life
and
he was a dictator
after all
and i i heard on the side of including
him
we have some video of carmen franco
who was uh his daughter and this is from
her wedding in 1950 oh huh
how many children
general
franco franco
just the one
just the one it's him on her
left that was a very grand affair
she married a
marquis or marquez
who was a a surgeon kind of a surgeon
playboy
he was a friend of
christian barnard in south africa
dr barnard was that his name we did the
first heart transplant and carmen's
husband did the first heart transplant
in in spain what happened to carmen
carmen lives on
and her children and grandchildren have
lived
quite difficult lives quite difficult
carmen herself has lived with a great
deal of grace and and poise
she is a kind of she's a symbol of
neo-fascism there's just a few fascists
left in
spain but she is a bit of a a grand lady
and one thing i discovered in this book
is that well it may be true that fathers
in general
especially prized their daughters
especially a firstborn daughter some
people say there's nothing like the
relationship between a father and a
daughter especially a firstborn daughter
and franco
had
only one child and that child was this
girl
and he absolutely adored her she was the
greatest brightest thing in his life
and she felt the same about him and they
always lived till the end of his life
pretty near each other and spent a lot
of time together it was the most prized
relationship in franco's life by far
what number of book is this for you
this is my i say my second real book i
have a collection which i don't count as
a real book a collection of journalism
and speeches and things like that as i
was reading your background i wanted to
ask this question all along
what's it like to write about monsters
and their children
and dictators and all of the horrible
things that you report in this book
compared to all the time you spend
writing about music
and explain how
how much writing you do about music
well i'm a political journalist and a
music critic and i say that i have a day
job and a night job really and music
criticism is my night job
and i like the balance i don't think i'd
like to do all of one
i must say
i i was pretty happy
finishing children of monsters i was
glad to begin it i was glad to do it
and i was glad to wash my hands of it
uh i wrote before that a history of the
nobel peace prize and i was sort of
reluctant to see that end i quite
enjoyed doing it and wrestling with the
big issues of war and peace and meeting
all the characters though some of them
are unsavory
but um
to have written this book about the sons
and daughters of dictators you rub up
against a lot of unpleasantness
and i tell a story about here's a boast
here's something name droppy my friend
paul johnson
whom i love
his daughter a british historian
he um
he wrote a book called
creators i think then he wrote a book
called intellectuals and one on heroes
and maybe comedians
and he was doing a series of
sketches of lives and categories and he
was going to do one called monsters
and he called it off but he didn't want
to spend so much time with the material
but he did later on write a brief life
of stalin and i asked him was that left
over from your research into your bigger
book on monsters and he said yes you
wanted to use that material but if you
think about it you wrote about franco
from spain and he wrote about mussolini
from italy and you wrote about stalin
he's not european but then you wrote
about hitler
what what is it about these dictators
that came out of europe
that life that they lived compared to
the kind of people you write about the
the people that wrote symphonies and
operas yeah how does that come out of
the same body yes
these dictators had a great will to
power a great thirst for power
and they imagined themselves
doing good
they deluded themselves that they were
doing good for the great masses they
didn't think of themselves as on ego
trips necessarily
they almost always had a rationale
uh some fake
humanitarian
or governmental rationale
and the
composers and other artists
really i think the best of them were
born to do what they did
the best artists i think are born to do
what they do and they can do no other
they're compelled to do it
but i'm afraid to say that some of these
dictators even from from boyhood
feel themselves
to fit to rule hitler for example
watched and listened to uh wagner's
opera rienzi over and over again and
memorized great swaths of it
and he thought he would be a great
imperial
leader
from very early on
but people often talk about this is just
an aside people often talk about hitler
and wagner probably his favorite work of
art was a humble operetta lahar's merry
widow he in fact awarded the composer
when he was chancellor
now you write for the national review
senior editor there how long have you
been with an action review
since the late 90s
what did you do before that i worked for
the weekly standard here in washington
under bill crystal and that gang and it
was a joy
and it was a joy later to work with rich
lowery and william buckley jr in the nr
gang how long did you write speeches for
george w bush
partly at all i wouldn't even say i
wrote speeches um
in
the 2000 campaign i took a six-week
leave of absence from national review
the last six weeks of the campaign
mid-september to election day
and went to austin and assisted the
speech writing team
and i flew back home to new york the
next day the day after the election day
but the election wasn't decided until
mid-december
so that was my experience and i enjoyed
it a great deal and i remain a great
admirer
of bush 43 and his father for that
matter where you from originally ann
arbor michigan
i call it a a small citadel of the left
and i sometimes describe myself because
i'm a reagan conservative as a backlash
baby
and i tease ann arbor in my column i get
great material out of ann arbor but i do
have fondness for it i really do
and i think you can sort of tell when i
write about it
i'm an ann arborite mom and dad were
from there what did they do there
my father was an educator primarily a
teacher
principal
coach that kind of thing
my mother has long been an artist a
painter
and if people want to read your writing
about
the composers
where do they find it well i'm user
critic of the new criterion i do some
music writing for national review as
well but i am the music critic of the
new criterion which is the arts and
letters journal founded in 1982
by hilton cramer
the late art critic and samuel lippmann
the late scholar and pianist
i have to say though if you want to read
a lot of what you write about composers
you can get it through google you can
sure put your name in and it's there in
one form what a tool and you also wrote
for the new york sun for how long i did
for i wrote for the new york sun and
that incarnation uh in the 2000s because
it's an older newspaper
uh for the duration of its existence and
that incarnation which i think was about
six years
i was a music critic
university of michigan yes my hometown
yes back to the monsters uh-oh this
person is not a monster but is the
daughter one this is svetlana
hallelujah and she's talking in english
this was back in 1967 right about the
time she came to the united states
and perhaps the studies of history and
social sciences and economics and
marxism itself
made me
well a little bit critical to many
things which i could see around me
and to the things i could see
in in our country and in other
socialist countries
because it was not exactly what we were
taught theoretically
a lot of people know something about her
she wrote books you talk about it in
your book
but how did she relate to stalin how
many children did he have
officially speaking he had three he did
have others
he had one with the first wife and two
with a second wife he had two sons and a
daughter
and he and svetlana had a wonderful
relationship until svetlana was about
16.
they really adored each other
she was probably the light of his life
and she worshipped her father
her mother killed herself
when svetlana was six her older brother
vasily was 11.
but when svetlana turned about 16 she
had the problems of growing up as people
do and stalin kind of tired of her and
dropped her
and she really never saw him that much
after then why did she come to the
united states and how did she get here
it's a tangled story
i will cut to the chase
she had a relationship in near marriage
cosegan who is then the soviet number
one
would not let her marry this indian man
she had met an indian communist who was
losing his communism and i think
returning to hinduism
she met him in moscow his name was singh
and she went to kosigan to ask
permission to marry kosigan denied it
mr singh died and one of his wishes was
that his ashes be spread on the ganges
and
to leave the soviet union of course
fatlana needed permission and she went
back to cosigan cosigan said sure i'll
give you two weeks and you can't speak
to the press
and so off svetlana went earn in hand
to india
and she loved being there she loved
being outside the soviet union
and one fine day morning i believe she
walked into the u.s embassy
and asked for a political asylum
and our guy the american official on
duty said
so you say you're the daughter of stalin
v stalin
one of my favorite stories about
svetlana and there are a great many she
led a turbulent life
i want to bring up something which may
surprise you i just learned about this
the other night because i wrote a
magazine piece about svetlana adapted
from my book and a colleague he emailed
me and said he was youtubing around
and he found a show with woody allen and
bill buckley from 1967
and they were asked questions by the
audience both of them
and someone asked woody allen are you
surprised that george hamilton went to
the wedding
now what was that all about well
george hamilton the actor had dated
lyndon johnson's daughter linda
and she married chuck robb
and apparently hamilton was invited to
the wedding and was there
and then alan was asked something else
and alan said all i want to know is um
is george hamilton going to announce his
engagement to svetlana stalin who had
recently defected and that was the big
yuck
but you come into this
because i think you were at that wedding
i actually was yes 50 years ago did you
not escort lady bird the first lady down
the aisle i did yes i was in the
military at the time
well
speaking of moments in history
i just and i i i really didn't know what
that crack was about that woody allen
made on that tape which is youtubeable
but
that was that wedding in 1967 and george
hamilton was there and svetlana was very
much in the news
she was a sensation
then her star dimmed a little and she
grew greatly discontent and in fact
redefected to the soviet union in 1984
immediately regretted it wanted to leave
almost as soon as she got there she
would have been stuck there forever but
luckily for her gorbachev rose to power
and after 18 months he let her out
she landed at o'hare airport in chicago
saying i had to leave for a while to
realize how wonderful it was here
she led a very turbulent life as most of
these
sons and daughters do but she led a more
difficult life than most
and as i argue in my book i think some
kind of greatness lay within her because
she told the truth when it was very hard
to do and had a rebellion of conscience
against the soviet system and came back
and died in wisconsin eventually yes i
remember it from your book a nursing
home in richland center wisconsin
jump now to
idioming
and his son jafar but
jafar was one of
how many kids
i think about 60 i think is the official
or semi-official
count who was he anyway who's idi amin
idi amin was the dictator of uganda
uh in the 1970s
a quite vicious man a brutish man almost
a cartoon of a dictator he's some
people's idea of a dictator
be meddled belligerent sweating and he
was deposed in i think 1979 and he spent
a year under
gaddafi's protection in libya
and he lived out the remainder of his
days in jeddah saudi arabia
under the royal family's protection and
he kept having kids i think almost till
the very end i believe the span of his
children i believe the first ones born
in 1948
and the last one in the mid 90s that's
the span of his children
and believe it or not he he seems to
have been a pretty good dad to his brood
more like an army really they called him
big daddy he was jolly he was fun-loving
and
the kids
they're a mixed bag as you might imagine
jafar amin is being interviewed on
ugandan television
and it's in english so you can hear him
and it you gotta pay close attention to
what he says about his father idi amin
my father was a very mothering
individual
the only example of him is obama you
know
children who have lived with their
mothers have an incredibly sensitive
uh persona around
that their children are progeny
today i find negatives talked about him
but right then there was the caring and
the mothering the
the love
he was strict but he was very as any
father should be yeah he was expected to
be
you know he used silence with children
he was not the bowler he was he was not
the
he was a quiet type he had a quiet
brooding presence
but
that love
despite the fact that we were 60
children
he had enough love to go around yes yes
what were you thinking when you're
listening to that
um
well it's it's an outrage
and it
it
somehow soils the memory of all the
people the thousands of people whom i
mean murdered
and yet i call jafar a pretty stand-up
guy he's a complicated case he's a white
washer of his father and his crimes
at the same time he believes in
reconciliation efforts in uganda
he is pretty honest despite what you've
heard pretty straightforward he'll take
on all comers he took on me in a long
email interview
i must say i admire him he's obviously
conflicted to use the modern
psychological parlance
and i don't like the sort of living by
lies
at the same time
i think in different moods
he knows the wrong his father committed
and that's why he leads reconciliation
efforts in uganda and he does have some
clear
honest confessional moods which i
believe then pass
nikolai
and his wife elena or elena i did
pronounce it yeah don't know i say elena
here's 1989 this was when the wall came
down right in that time period and they
were is this the end this is the end
this christmas day i believe this is 17
seconds
what's that story
the ceausescus ruled romania together
for decades
they brutalized the country they spied
on everyone
he was a vicious dictator and he had a
full partner in his wife
elena
and they were brought down in december
1989 and executed as i remember on
christmas day
he goes it's interesting that everyone
has religion brian he goes singing the
international the communist hymn
i think it's a kind of prayer for him
she goes cursing her executioners in the
saltiest
romanian
that's how the two of them go out
what have they done to the romanians
when they were in power and how long
were they in power
i think he takes over the 1960s
doesn't he and he lasts all that time
and they had pretty tight control of
that country um
almost as tight as hoja had over albania
it was almost a perfect police state a
perfect little totalitarian environment
and they brutalized that country
everyone was held in the thrall of that
couple
and the state security agents just
control the entire country i know this
all started with you on that 2002 trip
to albania and we haven't seen hoja who
led that how long was he in charge
and i remember that the lid on that
country you didn't we didn't know
anything about that country before
it was opened up
yes um
north korea is famously called the
hermit kingdom but albania was a kind of
hermit kingdom too and so were other
dictatorships
he ruled from just after the war of
world war ii until he died i believe in
the mid 1980s here's what he looked like
and here's what he sounded like in
albania
[Music]
how many children did he have
three
he had two sons
and a daughter did you meet them no
no excuse me for laughing um
no
no um they they don't meet with people
like me uh they are real loyalists uh
the hojas
uh the children
and they believe their father you know
at least aalir does yeah you never know
some of these people brian i shouldn't
assume
some of these people may harbor doubts
that we know not
that they would never express i try to
be very careful about that also people
who say some things may believe another
how did hoja keep the lid on albania so
nobody could get in or out
well he sealed the country he had these
little defensive concrete allegedly
defensive concrete bunkers
all over the country he had a very
robust
secret police
uh it's a relatively small country and
it was completely under his heel in fact
one of his nicknames bestowed on him by
the party was soul force s-o-l-e
um only force and in albania that was
pretty much true
who was elena or who is elena fernandez
a daughter of castro
who
couldn't stand in cuba any longer and
defected in the 1990s
she did so the aid of a false passport
and a wig
she got out and then she wrote a book
a memoir of her life in cuba as castro's
daughter it is to use one of the worst
reviewers cliches searing it's a searing
book tells the truth about castro and
his dictatorship
and as i think i mentioned in my book
alina is as hard on herself
as she is on the old man it's a
fascinating book where is she now
miami let's watch her in 2009 she speaks
in english at ohio university
it is amazing the way totalitarianism
can absolutely control the bodies and
the mind of human beings the castro seem
to know exactly what to do control wise
during the 90s as a result of the fall
of the soviet union
cuba became a harder place to live in
because of a wrong economy ordinary
lives collapsed
schools almost closed food was
impossible to find electricity became a
few hours of luxury as water and public
transportation the revolution becomes a
dictatorship when the states owns your
personal life and if you try to do
something to improve it you're sent to
jail how many children did castro have
how many wives did he have
how many children
10 15 somewhere in there there is no
official count no one really knows we
trust that he knows he may not know
he probably does
he married early on long before he came
to power a beautiful girl
from a society girl
mirta diaz balart she was the sister of
uh
castro's a good friend and i believe law
school classmate not quite sure possibly
roommate
rafael diaz-balart
he had a couple of sons who became u.s
congressmen my dear friend lincoln
diaz-balart and his brother mario
their aunt mirta was briefly married to
fidel castro and they had one son called
little fidel or fidelito
it's unclear whether castro married
again most people think he
did but he himself denied it in an
interview with an admirer of his uh the
filmmaker oliver stone
when the pope was recently in cuba and
you saw that
what was your reaction
based on what you know about castro yeah
well i have i have met and interviewed
and written about and been somewhat
close to many cuban dissidents over the
years former political prisoners and
there's some of the people i admire the
most in all the world
and i think that democratic forces
should back them to the
hilt
uh
all what dictatorships most want
is that opponents be forgotten their
names not mentioned
and what the opponents most want the
democratic opponents
is some kind of attention some sign that
the world hasn't forgotten them
and i remember that jean kirkpatrick
when she was ambassador of the un named
the names of prisoners in the and the
gulag she named their very names
and when she later visited the soviet
union sakharov said to her
a bunch of people came kissinger and
some others they're in a vestibule and
soccerops building it was kind of dark
and he came down he's very ill of course
he said kirkpatsky kirkpatsky which of
you is kirkpatsky and they gestured to
gene
he said your name is known in every cell
in the gulag
and that's because of what she had done
for them
at the u.n
just saying their names in fact that's
how sakharov used his nobel lecture he
wasn't allowed to attend
but his wife did elena bonner
there was a good elena although she was
tough too believe me
and in that address
soccer off just pauses takes almost a
detour in the middle of addre in the
address
and reels off a hundred names of soviet
political just says their names through
his wife
that's what they wanted
islam gaddafi oh my
he was the son of gaddafi one of the
seven sons he was the one who tried to
go straight
who tried to be
a kind of western liberal or an arab
reformer he really wanted to he went
some way in that direction but in the
end when the libyan civil war started
he was loyal he went home
and he fought for the dictatorship he
did brutal things and now he's in prison
and wanted by the hague here he is in
2011 speaking in english
yesterday last year 10 years ago today
tomorrow
i'm the first person i'm first i'm
before all of them i'm the first person
10 years ago i said we need constitution
we need more freedom we need democracy
we need election i said this many many
times but now that didn't happen okay
and now you have an uprising no it's not
uprising now we have people who wants to
split the country east and west they
want to kill three or four states
now you have people who are terrifying
our people now you have terrorists you
have militia now the picture is
different it was an al jazeera interview
and uh he's in prison for what
during the war he acted as his father's
prime minister in effect
and they fired on unarmed civilians
and he was charged by the world court
with war crimes
and wanted for those he could not escape
libya he tried to libyan forces captured
him have been holding him prisoner ever
since
and the libyan authorities whatever they
are have refused to
extradite him to the hague what happened
to the other six children of gaddafi
i think three of them died in the war
three of them were killed in the libyan
civil war
two of them
managed to escape
three of them escaped one was sent back
by
niger or niger the african country one
of them was sent back
um he's in prison
so as saif al-islam qaddafi confusingly
had two sons named saif the other two
were in exile in the gulf
and how many times had gaddafi married
uh twice
he had one child with a first wife i
believe she was the daughter of a
general he was married very briefly to
her he took up with a nurse whom he met
when he was hospitalized and they had i
think seven further children
bashar al-assad
how many children did his father have
seems to me about six i think two
daughters and four sons how many wives
one
one so far as i know what happened to
this son that was killed the oldest
uh basel he was to be the successor he
was the golden boy he was the anointed
he was the heir he was the next dictator
and he was killed in a car crash he was
late for a flight it was a foggy morning
he was trying to catch a lufthansa
flight to germany he was in his new
sports car
and he went in the roundabout in front
of the airport and flipped and
died
and
the next
oldest brother bashar
was in london
practicing eye surgery
that was his role in life to be an
ophthalmologist he was
very quiet
shy he had no interest whatsoever in
dictatorship or politics or power
and when basel was killed in that crash
the old man assad called him home
immediately and began to groom him for
succession when the father died do you
remember
seems to me it was 2000
when hathas dies
here is bashar
al-assad currently the president of
syria
so it's not about europe
didn't accept them or impress them as
refugees it's about not dealing with the
cause stop if you are worried about them
stop supporting terrorists that's what
we think regarding the crisis this is
the core of the whole issue
that's just a few weeks ago what do you
think of him
that would take longer than we have uh
he has killed more than his father ever
dreamed of killing probably bashar has
along by the way his his right-hand man
or thug is his brother maher
these are really family businesses
dictatorships
uh bashar never wanted this
but he took up dictatorship with a
vengeance and he's done all the killing
necessary to keep the family business
going this is the only thing you can say
in his defense i don't know if defense
is the word but this is what some might
say and i will repeat it
if he falls his fellow alawites in syria
are slaughtered
so i believe in his mind it's kill or be
killed and who knows it may even be true
so in the end how long did this book
take to write
research
i i think i i think i spent a year
writing it
and what do you want somebody take away
from it
i would say there are two levels first
of all it's a collection of very very
interesting stories about all two
interesting lives all two fascinating
lives
you wouldn't wish this kind of life on
on most people really so it's a
collection of very interesting sometimes
lurid stories
but there are also points about
about tyranny about sonship or
daughtership about loyalty about nature
nurture
about politics and even about democracy
some of the early readers of this book
have said that they came away feeling so
grateful they live in a democratic
country with a rule of law in an
atmosphere of ordered liberty
i've heard that from
i think two three readers and i i'm sort
of impressed that wasn't my aim not from
a like or dislike
point of view but of all these 20
dictators which one would you like to
interview the most
probably one who has said the least and
who needs probing
uh
which one would that be i think i'd know
their answers in advance but it sounds
like it sounds like i'm dodging
i think i'd know their answers their
excuses their apologies their rationales
in advance
but i tell you who might be somewhat
forthcoming
frankly you saw jafar there on the
screen you might get something out of
amin
we're out of time jay nordlinger has
been our guest there's a lot of we
didn't get to discuss in this book
no no no no it's just a lot of details
that we didn't get into the book is
called children of monsters
our guest is a senior editor at national
review and this is an inquiry into the
sons and daughters of dictators thank
you very much for joining us i'm such a
brian lamb fan thank you so much it's an
honor it's an honor thank you
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
if you enjoyed this week's q a interview